En este video vamos a ver algunos ejemplos
de cómo se resuelven las ecuaciones,
van a ser ecuaciones muy sencillas, los pasos
van a ser muy fáciles,
pero lo que realmente quiero que
quede claro en este video es
¿por qué hacemos los pasos que hacemos cuando estamos tratando de resolver una ecuación?
Entonces, empecemos con el primer ejemplo,
"x" más 11 es igual a 7.
En esta ecuación, déjame la vuelvo a escribir,
"x" más 11 es igual a 7,
ok, aquí lo que estamos buscando es qué número cuando se lo sumamos a 11 nos da 7
y seguramente puedes obtener la respuesta rapidísimo ahorita, haciéndolo en tu cabeza,
pero vamos a hacerlo paso a paso de una
forma sistemática
para que cuando estemos resolviendo ecuaciones mucho más complicadas
sea más fácil saber exactamente que es
lo que tenemos que hacer.
Ok, entonces, cuando queremos resolver una ecuación como ésta, lo que realmente queremos
hacer es encontrar cuál es este valor de la "x", ok, queremos llegar a algo de la forma
"x" es igual a...
y aquí...
un número que si lo colocamos justo en el
lugar de la "x", se satisface esta ecuación,
ok. Que ese número más 11, realmente es igual a 7.
Ahora, para encontrar esta "x", pues ya
tenemos bastante ¿no?
o sea ya tenemos que esta "x" más este 11
es igual en este caso a 7, entonces lo único
que necesitamos para encontrar a qué es igual
a "x" es deshacernos de este +11,
ok, nos queremos deshacer de este +11, pero pues no
podemos simplemente tacharlo por acá,
para deshacernos de él, lo que podemos hacer es
restarle 11, ok, le estamos sumando -11,
pero si le estamos sumando -11 a este lado del
igual, pues también se lo tenemos que sumar
a este lado del igual, porque sino este signo
de igual que nos está diciendo que esta cosa
es igual a esta cosa, ya no nos estaría
diciendo algo verdadero.
ok. Lo que realmente tenemos aquí es que "x"
más 11, o sea todo esto es igual a 7, ok,
eso es lo que nosotros sabemos que es cierto,
estas dos cantidades son iguales y si nosotros
queremos que esta igualdad se preserve y le queremos sumar un -11 al lado izquierdo del igual
entonces también tenemos que sumarle
un -11 a este lado del igual,
ok, entonces en el fondo lo que estamos diciendo, es que cualquier cosa que le hagamos al lado izquierdo
del igual, se lo tenemos que hacer al lado derecho del igual, para que sigan siendo iguales
y sigamos pudiendo poner este símbolo de igual, entonces empecemos por el lado izquierdo
de esta igualdad, tenemos aquí -11 más "x" más 11.
que es lo mismo que "x" más 11 menos 11, o sea,
"x" más 0, que es simplemente una "x"
y eso es igual a 7 menos 11
y resolver esta resta es muy sencillo, si no te acuerdas
vamos a poner una recta numérica,
tenemos aquí al 0 y entonces saltamos
a la derecha 7 veces...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, este es el 7...
y ahora saltamos hacia la izquierda 11 veces...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11 veces...
entonces 7 menos 11,
es este lugar en la recta numérica que es a ver aquí tenemos el 0, -1, -2, -3 y -4, ok.
Entonces "x" es igual a -4...
"x" es igual a -4, entonces ya terminamos
con la primera ecuación, ya encontramos a
cuánto es igual esta "x",
así es que vamos con la siguiente ecuación y aquí lo que
tenemos es que 7 por "x" es igual a 21, ok.
Esta es otra ecuación distinta a ésta, esta "x" no tiene porque tener nada que ver con esta "x".
Ok, entonces vamos a empezar por reescribir
esta ecuación,
7 por "x" es igual a 21 y lo que estamos buscando
es algo de esta forma, o sea, tenemos aquí,
"x" igual a alguna otra cosa, donde en este
caso esa otra cosa, cuando la multiplicamos
por 7 nos da 21, ok, estamos buscando que
número debería de ir aquí.
¿A qué es igual esta "x"?
A ver y aquí lo que tengo, es 7 por "x", si yo fuera a dividir esta expresión entre un 7,
entonces lo que tengo es 7 por alguna cosa dividido entre 7 y eso, sea cual sea esa cosa,
es simplemente esta cosa, ¿cierto?
Y entonces ya tenemos aquí a la "x" solita
de este lado del igual, ahora si yo divido
el lado izquierdo del igual entre 7, entonces
también tengo que dividir el lado derecho
del igual entre 7, ok, todo lo que le hagamos al lado izquierdo se lo tenemos que hacer al lado derecho.
Ok. Entonces ya que tenemos esta igualdad así, "x" por 7 entre 7, eso es simplemente una "x"
y esto es igual a 21 entre 7, 3 por 7 = 21,
entonces aquí lo que va es un 3,
21 entre 7 es igual a 3, así es que "x" es igual a 3 y podemos verificar que tenemos el resultado correcto
y para hacer eso, lo único que tenemos que hacer es en esta ecuación sustituir a "x",  ok.
Entonces en todos los lugares de esta ecuación
donde aparece el "x", que o sea, aquí
tenemos que escribir un 3 y verificar que
realmente se dé esta igualdad,
pero si se da esta igualdad ¿no? o sea porque aquí en lugar de una "x" ponemos un 3
y entonces aquí lo que tenemos es que 7
por 3 es igual a 21 y eso si es cierto ¿no?
Entonces está muy bien eso de que "x" sea igual a 3.
Y lo mismo podemos hacer con esta ecuación, ok, nosotros estamos diciendo que "x" es igual a -4,
para verificarlo puedes aquí en lugar de la "x",
podemos poner un -4
y ver que realmente esto sea igual a esto, pero eso si es cierto porque -4 más 11 eso es igual a 11 menos 4
y eso sí es igual a 7, entonces "x" si es igual a -4.
Bien, ahora vamos con la siguiente.
Y se ve como que es una ecuación un poquito más complicada, pero vas a ver que está super sencilla.
Ok, entonces tenemos "5x" entre 12 es igual a 2/3,
entonces que te parece si multiplicamos por 12/5, ok.
Ahora si lo quiero hacer de este lado del igual, entonces para preservar este signo de igual,
también lo tengo que hacer del lado derecho del igual,
o sea que aquí tengo que multiplicar por 12/5.
Ahora, ¿para qué quería yo multiplicar por 12/5?
Pues resulta que si multiplicas por 12/5 a
la hora de hacer esta multiplicación,
este 12 se va a cancelar con este 12 y este 5 se
va a cancelar con este 5,
entonces aquí nos queda simplemente esta "x".
Ok, nos queda la "x" igual a 2/3 por 12/5, ahora,
este 12 también lo podemos ver como
un 3 por 4...
y entonces este 3 se va a cancelar con este 3, y nos queda simplemente 2 por 4 entre 5, o sea, 8/5.
Entonces "x" es igual a 8/5.
Ahora, aquí tú puedes saltar y decirme,
¡Ey, Sal!
oye aquí estás haciendo otra cosa distinta
a lo que estás haciendo aquí,
aquí éste, el coeficiente de la "x" en un 7,
ok, el coeficiente
es el número por el cual estás multiplicando a la "x",
en este caso...
y bueno aquí, lo que haces para resolver esta ecuación es dividir entre el coeficiente de la "x"
de los dos lados del igual, ok,
mientras que en este caso,
en lugar de dividir entre el coeficiente de la "x",
que en este caso es 5/12,
lo que haces es multiplicar por el inverso del coeficiente, que el inverso de 5/12 es 12/5,
y aquí estamos multiplicando por 12/5,
en lugar de dividir entre 5/12,
ok, pero bueno resulta que estos dos métodos son
exactamente equivalentes.
Las dos son muy buenas formas de resolver
ecuaciones y por ejemplo aquí, en lugar de
dividir entre 7, podríamos haber multiplicado
por el inverso de 7, ok, si tenemos por aquí
"7x" igual a 21, podemos en lugar de dividir
entre 7 de los dos lados del igual,
podemos simplemente multiplicar por el inverso de 7, ok, y el inverso de 7 es ese número
que si lo multiplicamos por 7 nos da 1, entonces
multiplicamos de este lado, así es que tenemos
que multiplicar de este lado también, por
1 entre 7 y entonces 1 entre 7 por 7,
eso se cancela y nos queda simplemente
"1x" igual a 21 por 1 entre 7,
eso es simplemente 21 entre 7 que es igual a 3, ok.
Entonces "x" es igual a 3, dos formas distintas de resolver esta ecuación, nos dieron exactamente
el mismo resultado y también se puede
hacer con esta ecuación.
Entonces tenemos por aquí, 5/12 de "x"...
a ver, a ver...
esta cantidad es exactamente igual a esta cantidad, ok, lo único que hice fue separar la "x" del coeficiente,
ok, 5 por "x" entre 12 es exactamente
igual a 5 entre 12 por "x".
Ok. Y entonces tenemos aquí que la ecuación es
5/12 por "x" es igual a 2/3,
pero ahora en lugar de multiplicar por el inverso de 5/12, que es 12/5, lo que vamos a hacer es dividir
a todo entre 5/12, ok, si dividimos del lado izquierdo, también tenemos que dividir del lado derecho,
Bueno, pero resulta que estas cantidades son
exactamente iguales a estas cantidades,
porque resulta que dividir entre una fracción es exactamente igual a multiplicar por el inverso
de esa fracción, ok, si queremos resolver
esta división, lo que hacemos es la regla
del sandwich que lo que hace es pasar éste
para acá multiplicando y éste para acá
multiplicando, ok, esa es la regla del sandwich y eso es exactamente igual a multiplicar por 12/5.
Entonces, finalmente, no importa si lo que haces es dividir entre el coeficiente de la "x"
o multiplicar por el inverso del coeficiente de la "x", ok.
Estas dos operaciones son exactamente equivalentes,
entonces pues, vamos a seguir haciendo ejemplos,
ahora vamos a resolver estas ecuaciones...
y todas estas ecuaciones en realidad las vamos
a hacer para que quede muy claro que, no solo
podemos resolver ecuaciones que tengan "x",
arriba teníamos un bonche de ecuaciones con
una variable "x" que queríamos encontrar
y aquí lo que tenemos son un bonche de ecuaciones
con por ejemplo una "q", una "z", una "s"...
y lo que vamos a hacer es encontrar cuanto tiene que valer "q" para que se dé esta igualdad
o cuanto tiene que ser "z" para que si a "z" le sumas 1.1 te quede 3.0001
ó cuanto tiene que valer la "s" para que
esta igualdad sea cierta.
Ok, entonces empecemos por la "q", aquí lo que tenemos es que "q" menos 13 es igual a -13
y lo que queremos es encontrar esta "q",
queremos dejar a esta "q" solita
para que nos quede una igualdad de la forma
"q" es igual a... y otra cosa por ahí.
Ok, si llegamos a eso, ya resolvimos esta ecuación,
o sea, ya encontramos cuánto vale "q".
¿Y cómo le vamos a hacer para dejar solita a la "q"?
ok. ¿Cómo nos vamos a deshacer de este -13?
Pues que te parece si aquí le sumamos 13,
sumamos 13 del lado izquierdo del igual,
entonces tenemos que sumar 13 del lado
derecho del igual y ¿para qué hice eso?
Pues porque 13 más -13, o sea, 13 menos 13
es igual a 0 y entonces aquí nos queda 0
más "q", o sea que nos queda la "q" solita
del lado izquierdo del igual,
ok, 13 más "q" menos 13, es simplemente una "q" y eso,
como seguimos la regla de que todo lo que
le hagamos al lado izquierdo se lo tenemos
que hacer del lado derecho, entonces esto,
o sea "q" es exactamente igual a -13 más 13,
lo cual es simplemente un 0,
ok, entonces "q" es igual a 0.
Y podemos verificarlo sustituyendo
a "q" en esta igualdad,
así es que tenemos "q" igual a 0, que es 0,
menos 13... -13 igual a -13...
Y sí, definitivamente -13 sí es igual a -13, ok, entonces...
listo.
¡Ey! se nos olvido checar el inciso anterior, ok,
entonces eso es lo más padre del álgebra,
siempre puedes checar tu respuesta, si es
que tienes tiempo suficiente.
Ok, una vez que encuentras la respuesta, siempre
puedes checar si es la respuesta correcta.
Ok, entonces vamos a ver...
Aquí nosotros estamos diciendo que la
respuesta correcta es 8/5,
así es que lo que estamos diciendo es que 5 entre 12 por 8/5 es igual a 2/3.
Ok, el 5 con el 5 se cancelan, el 12 lo podemos ver como un 4 por 3, el 8 lo podemos ver como un 4 por 2,
entonces este 2 se cancela con este 2 y nos queda simplemente este 3 y este 2,
o sea que nos queda 2/3... 2/3...
Así es que sí, ésta si es la respuesta correcta.
Muy bien, que bueno que checamos,
ahora si vamos con este ejercicio...
Entonces, tenemos "z" más 1.1 es igual a 3.0001, ok.
Bien, queremos encontrar a cuánto es igual esta "z", ok, queremos algo de la forma "z" es igual a...
y ¡tan, tan, tan! la respuesta...
pero, para hacer eso, tenemos que
deshacernos de este 1.1,
entonces yo propongo que restemos 1.1 de los dos lados, recuerda, muy importante,
nosotros sabemos que esto es exactamente igual
a esto y si queremos preservar esta igualdad,
entonces si le sumamos algo a este lado del igual, también se lo tenemos que sumar a este otro lado, ok.
Cualquier cosa que se nos ocurra hacerle a
este lado del igual, se lo tenemos que hacer
a este lado del igual para seguir teniendo una igualdad.
Ok, entonces aquí estamos sumando éste con éste y hacemos eso porque éste más éste se van a cancelar,
1.1 menos 1.1 se cancelan,
entonces nada más nos queda la "z".
Así es que tenemos que "z" es igual
a 3.0001 menos 1.1...
y sabes qué, creo hacer esta operación es la parte más difícil de resolver esta ecuación,
entonces vamos a hacerla con calma, tenemos
aquí 3.0001menos 1.1, lo que queremos hacer
aquí es alinear el punto decimal, así es que ponemos el punto decimal justo por acá,
entonces tenemos por aquí un 1.1 y lo estamos
restando y de hecho, podemos agregar
todos los 0 que queramos a la derecha del punto
decimal, entonces aquí tenemos, 1 menos 0,
eso es un 1, 0 menos 0, eso es un 0, 0 menos
0 = 0 y aquí es donde se pone interesante
0 menos 1, pues lo que tenemos que hacer es
todo ese relajo de pedirle prestado a las
unidades de la izquierda, entonces aquí en lugar de tener un 3 vamos a tener un 2
y aquí en lugar de tener 0 unidades, vamos a tener
10 unidades y entonces 10 menos 1
nos queda 9 y 2 menos 1 nos queda 1, entonces nuestra
respuesta es que "z"
es igual a 1.9001 y podemos verificar esta
respuesta muy fácilmente.
Tenemos aquí, "z"...
"z"...
entonces le sumamos 1.1 y queremos si eso
es igual a 3.0001, entonces vamos a sumar,
alineamos los decimales, aquí tenemos 1.1,
estamos sumando...
Entonces, 0 más 1 = 1...
0, 0, 0... 0 más 0 = 0, 0 más 0 = 0, 1 más 9 eso es 10,
o sea que aquí ponemos un 0 y ponemos un 1 por acá,
0 y llevamos 1, el punto decimal
y finalmente 1 más 1 más 1, que llevábamos, eso es 3,
que definitivamente si es igual a 3.0001, así es que muy bien, ya verificamos, esta si es una respuesta correcta.
Y vamos con el siguiente, el último ejercicio,
nuestra última ecuación,
tenemos aquí que 21 por "s" es igual a 3, ok,
entonces tenemos que 21 por algo,
que queremos encontrar, es igual a 3.
Así es que para encontrar ese algo, lo que podemos hacer es multiplicar por 1 entre 21,
de los dos lados del igual.
Entonces 1 entre 21 y el 21 se cancelan, porque
21 entre 21 es igual a 1,
entonces tenemos 1 por "s" y nos queda "s" es igual a 3 por 1 entre 21 que es 3 entre 21,
que a su vez es igual a...
21 es 3 por 7 ¿no?
entonces aquí tenemos 1 entre 7, ok, podemos
verificar que "s" es igual a 1 entre 7,
sustituyendo a "s" en esta ecuación, ok,
entonces tenemos aquí,
21 por 1 entre 7 y eso es igual a 3, así es que...
"s" igual a 1/7 es la respuesta correcta.
Muy bien, espero que encuentres este video
muy útil y nos vemos en el próximo video.